[Music]
hidey-ho reject nation of Greg Alva I'm
John Humphrey we are about to do an
in-depth spoiler talk for spider-man far
from home before we sling on over into
this review see what I did there
I would like to give a big thank you to
our video sponsor today I'm so excited
to be partnering with them I joked about
that we're gonna be sponsored by them
one day and now here they are Skillshare
that's right guys if you're somehow not
familiar with Skillshare if you live
under a rock
Skillshare is an online community for
creators of all levels that offers
courses in art business design a whole
bunch of different things with a premium
membership to Skillshare you can gain
unlimited access to more than 25,000
courses so you can find the community
and learning sensibility that's right
for you so far with our trial membership
we've been checking out the film and
cinematography courses brushing up on
the old skills if you're looking to bump
up your work to movie quality Ryan booth
gives an awesome class on DIY
cinematography or if you're itching to
get out and shoot with what's already in
your pocket Cielo de la Paz has a great
crash course on shooting and editing
video with your iPhone and if all this
wasn't enough Skillshare is giving away
two three months of membership unlimited
trial access to any and all real reject
subscribers who go down into that
description box and hit our special link
then after that this service is only
around ten dollars a month so hitter a
special link and join more than 7
million creators who are learning
sharing and growing over on Skillshare
now let's swing on over to that review
transition alright guys so we got Andrew
Gordon here with us how's he doing
Andrew I'm doing how are you doing Greg
I'm doing good I'm doing good all right
let's hop right into it Thank You Scotia
for sponsoring this and thank you Luke
gaming for letting us prop our boxes up
here for the microphone we had to fit
all three of us in the shot today for us
we're not gonna do like a whole
breakdown of the entire movie we have
some basic notes of what we ultimately
would like to cover something comes up
something comes up I guess I would kick
it off right away
with this the big reveal the stereos a
bad guy I gotta ask you guys did you did
you have any doubt at all though that he
wouldn't be a bad guy like did the movie
ever have you going not the film itself
didn't and that goes back to something
we touched on the non-spoiler review
because like I kept feeling like if they
just added a couple more scenes I might
have bought it but I kept feeling the
movie was trying to get to something
with that with all we know about
Mysterio I thought they might have taken
a before the movie I was like oh maybe
they will make him some kind of weird
good guy or do something different and I
was hoping like watch him turn into a
bad guy yeah or having become one of
those antagonists who isn't a bad guy
but is somehow yeah opposed directly to
our heroes or whatever I feel like most
of us who have a basic understanding of
the Mysterio character watch the
trailers and were like elementals were
fake mr. Astor knew like we all sort of
predicted that I know we're not the only
ones pretty much everyone thought that
but I thought the handling of it was
done pretty well I guess my one thing is
I wish they sort of did a little
something more with the personality of
Quinn and back is that his real name no
it's not was real name right that's a
Jake Gyllenhaal's an actor ah the
character is that is his character is he
actually called Quinton back because I
know that slightly made me question it
because I was like wait a minute
wouldn't they have like this whole
background on him then that he worked
for thirst if his name was weighted back
he helped create the barf technology and
all these things when they have been
able to find that switch that was a cool
callback and yeah you would think that
especially if it's stark tech in any way
shape or form this security would be
asked for not have that info or maybe
they maybe even managed to erase it
because you've worked within the company
or something like yeah I agree with you
but I mean getting back to your question
on did we see if Mysterio was going to
be a bag I mean if you like you guys say
if you know anything about Mysteria you
knew he's probably gonna be but I
thought at first they were gonna angle
more into the alright he's a good guy
who's turning into a bad guy like four
reasons as opposed to you know what
found out later on in the film during
that bar scene is that Tony had fired
him because he was unstable
yes everyone so far in a spider-man
movie their hatred stems for its Tony
Stark you know what that bar scene where
he was like revealing everything and
then we got the whole projection I mean
I thought that was just done in a very
interesting way I just yeah I'm not
saying the movie was lifeless up until
that point just the first half was just
you know okay predictable and by the
numbers yeah and because of the fact
that we all saw it coming from the
trailers yeah I felt like the movie
could have done a little bit of a better
job at selling us more in terms of maybe
giving Quentin back that's why I brought
his name up I mean quit him back a bit
more of a personality I get what he was
doing he was trying to channel the
superhero model in order to sell it and
even like talks about that like people
in listening if you shoot lasers out of
your hands and you have a cape like you
know riffs on that at the same time
though I thought his personality was so
like bland before that and I got the
intention of it I like that John Watts
did not have any lingering shots on him
before the big reveal
especially when they close the door at
the bar of like oh look at the look he's
given maybe he's a bad guy you know and
like now not have these like lingering
mysterious the lingering mysterious
shots of maybe he really is a bad guy
yes weird it's like it doesn't do a
whole lot to suggest that he is and it
also doesn't do a whole lot to suggest
that he's not the credit I will give to
them is that when the reversal does come
down I still was bummed out in context
and I still cared I was still invested
in that moment I just yeah would have
liked to have bought it there were also
a couple lines of his that he did like
you know where he was like interacting
with Peters like Peter don't ever but
like don't ever apologize for being the
smartest guy in the room like there were
a couple exchanges between I'm not
saying like personality-wise he was like
oh my god I am so invested in this
character but there were definitely some
interactions between him and Peter Rose
like I'm actually enjoying you know at
least the dialogue here I'll give you
that that the mentorship thing that they
wanted to sell us on I bought I bought
into why Peter would ultimately be
persuaded by him and even give over the
Edith glasses spoiler in the right place
but talking about that bar scene I loved
it
he gives us like giant exposition dump
to explain everything and the only
reason that exposition dump works is
because of Jake Gyllenhaal's performance
yeah just how gleeful he is and this
idea of like she's had to do to sell
this thing and now they finally got the
ultimate goal that there's hope for what
they want to accomplish I did love they
decided to change the background of
Quinn him back like you still got the
essential ingredients a guy who could
create illusions his name's Quinn and
back fishball helmet which will have
exactly the costume designer thing I
thought was really great to keep that
the idea of giving him a team to work
with his exact ran is stark tech that
made it work so much better in terms of
reality because I guess I was wondering
if we're gonna watch and turn into a bad
guy cuz I was thinking are they gonna do
some reveal where he's a really a
stuntman and stuff because that just
won't I just won't buy that yeah but
what they went with for this story to
make it believable I thought was great
in the reveal there was a lot of oh like
cool things I when they brought it back
to the barf technology I love how we
just casually say it like it's not funny
once he lays yeah I was gonna say once
he lays the acronym out your sleep okay
yeah yeah when they went back to the
barf technology from Civil War a I was
happy they brought it up because I
remember they brought it up in Civil War
and I thought endgame was gonna do
something with it and the fact that
they've been saying this is the actual
closing chapter 2 phase 3 they managed
to tie that technology in made me
satisfied as a fan of the MCU I thought
that was a really cool thing to infuse
in here but then even bring you back a
Peter Billingsley yeah Christmas story I
wouldn't have reckon I mean unless
you're like a Peter Billingsley fan no
Peter people through brought out Peter
Billingsley more than they know that
characters name they even bring it back
even more full circle with Iron Man one
I thought was a neat addition I thought
we were gonna get that with everyone in
the team small characters yeah I also
like the fact to now when you watch
Captain America Civil War and you see
you know Tony doing the bye
augmented retro framing or the bar scene
you know Jake Gyllenhaal's character is
off to the side next time you watch a
civil war so they got a George Lucas
this and throw them in there he was
there he's right there guys we sent our
non-spoiler review the first half by the
numbers it's pretty much what you saw on
the trailers their stuff will probably
go back to you to talk a little bit more
in depth about of what we really loved
about it and then issues that I
personally had a mention in the
non-spoiler or the thing about Aunt May
that I want to talk about a little bit
later but let's stick to this portion of
the movie as it keeps going we'll get to
the post-credits scenes guys don't worry
as it keeps going there was a post
credit scene this movie oh my god
laughter Danna Lefter who left early a
mess
take a poop so legit reason one other
element I really liked in that second
half - I was one of the things that was
really clicking for me in the first half
was the whole thing with MJ their
relationship their dynamics the
enhancement of her character I know
there's that whole thing and there's a
little bit of a I don't know uncle
outcry but a negative reaction to when
zendaya says my name is actually MJ in
homecoming who look that's not my
mary-jane
I like that they have committed to know
her name is MJ we're gonna call her MJ
we're gonna commit to this portrayal
that we have and she's so opposite to
Peter but this movie you really see
their chemistry really come into play I
wish the trailers did not reveal that
she knew that he's spider-man they cover
it because that actually wound up as an
actual surprise to me in the movie
itself really and the trailer she
flat-out says you're spider-man
well yeah but but there's a cut back
when she goes I'm just I'm just messing
with you like and there's a relief mode
at least in some of the ads I've seen
they do that initially in that moment I
was like okay when's the joke gonna wrap
up I've seen this in the trailer and
then it didn't and I was like oh damn
well the handling of that moment I
thought was great when he realizes that
okay there's this illusion technology
he's like turns around yeah it's such a
different way for him to reveal he's
spider-man because it seems like when he
reveals it it's never
because he just really wants to hear we
got no choice but to show now you know
ya know and also to the jig was kind of
by me he's always leaving to go
somewhere I mean she even mentioned
Washington DC and then when he just left
the Opera and then then that night what
was his name the the monkey you night
the night yeah monkey was out there so I
mean well incidental I think that's one
of the things I really credit this film
for is the fact that they know that this
is the MCU let's say there's no MCU it
was just a spider-man movie people could
detect this right but it's even more
likely that they could figure it out in
the world they live in
oh you know what I mean with what they
called the blip which is a funny name to
give the snapping in the decimation with
the world they live in now I like that
the characters were pretty smart and I
liked how Peter himself was like with
Washington me being here spire maybe
they're gonna figure it out he was aware
that they could figure it out and I
thought that was some really neat
writing that they infuse in here hopping
forward a little bit more the mysterious
sequences when when he's able to go into
you know like mess with Peter in order
to he could find out who Peter told
about the whole Mysterio truths and
stuff also regained that technology
thing back those sequences were
mind-blowing like we mentioned we saw
this in 40 X in 3d who's really great
there but I think even without having
seen it in that format I'd still be like
mind blown by it because it's not
exactly a dr. strange sequence it's
still very in tune with what Mysterio
can pull off and what Mysterio can
actually do what you guys think about
those moments oh I'm in command just the
the illusions were outstanding the
visual effects they get so much credit
that team and just John watts
I for like how he had the camera working
and all that like I mean I was just kept
on hold like I couldn't even tell what
was going on but in a good way and like
them like this really feels like
Mysterio and it's just some of the most
mind-blowing visual effects I've seen in
a while just with how they were doing
and how like spider-man couldn't even
tell where he was going in and pan that
arc he gets later but for me I thought
that first the first fight he had with
Mysterio and the that was unbelievable
with the illusions we were getting in
there and I just couldn't tell what was
what that's what you're supposed to do
when you're with mister like they just
did
right yeah they're good at putting you
in Peter shoes with that because he is
clever and he is really disorienting
when he's in attack mode and yeah the
the surreal sequences are some of my
favorites across the Marvel movies when
they really throw down on innovative
visuals and really realizing those
things that you thought were unfilmable
from comics of the past because I
remember even when they announced the
Mysterio was gonna be the villain for
this movie people were like I don't know
this could be really silly I was dazzled
you know when Doctor Strange got all
crazy and this kind of took that just in
a different direction for me with those
sequences it was very personal the idea
of the illusions was all within the
Peter Parker mindset where's it look
like Doctor Strange you're like looking
all those crazy cosmic stuff you know
like a whole bunch of mumbo-jumbo going
on but everything here felt very
specifically calculated of what they
wanted to infuse in here right down to
going to the graveyard
Iron Man Marvel Zombies yeah like that
was really I was gonna be Ben Parker
actually when we first got to the green
side don't ask man Parker no on a
briefcase also the way the sequence
played out with like Nick Fury shooting
Mysterio I thought was also great
because I had that bummer of a moment of
oh okay so what's gonna happen mr. is
gonna get captures gonna break out gonna
have a big throw back for now like I
might start just going through like what
would a Marvel movie do and then oh they
did it right away that seems like twists
upon twists upon twisted one twist which
is what you need for a great memorable
Mysterio sequence I'm so glad they
didn't even tease any of that in the
trailers yeah that made me very like
most of the trailer footage is any
sequence of the elementals because
that's all part of the illusion game
like pretty much stuck to committing to
the illusion game and putting you in the
mindset of what our protagonists think
is going on yeah and not showing you at
all the reality of the situation what I
gotta say though is like Tom haulin had
a moment in here that I just loved and I
don't know if this moment really stands
out to you guys but for me when I think
of a moment at I love with
Holland's performance I specifically
flashed to after like where is he in
after he's on the train Denis and
another meant the guys in the prison
yeah cousin in the native language I
think it's Nederland or whatever
okay that's yeah he's like in the in the
flower field and then happy shows up
that moment when what he's like proved
to me you're happy tell me something
really happy would know like how on edge
he is of the the the the culmination of
the stresses he's gone through this very
specific breaking point yeah he's like
fraught in that moment yeah really
tangible that to me is my favorite like
a gravitas moment of Peter Parker out of
any moment here in all of the spider-man
movies I mean a lot of people probably
go to what he's crying in front of Tony
Stark or when he's you know get up
spider-man people will probably
reference those but there was something
about the performance there that just
really clicked for me on a pure core
level because he is like the complete
anchor of that moment it doesn't rely on
anybody else you know I mean the happy
is a part of that moment I guess it's
the effect to that shows you mister he's
really starting to take a toll on Peter
but just think about everything he's
gone through so far in this film on top
of everything else he's gone through and
the other films I mean he's just found a
new mentor who's already been betrayed
he can't get a minute alone with MJ
without some guy you know taking a
picture of him where it looks like he's
having sex with a he's dealing with a
lot at the end of these he's just a 16
year old kid I think like you say he
just really got me in that moment I just
found myself like beyond invested when
he was like speaking there like it's
very relatable to what he's been going
through completely agree that moment
definitely stands out in his performance
for sure and in the next scene bill dome
is who the building of the suit can't
reminded me a little of Mission
Impossible with the face when they're
doing the facia espionage vibes
throughout the film yeah I thought I
thought it was well justified the
different uses of suits you know like
well we would see like the black
spider-man student here were like why is
he doing that
and then you're like well people will be
able to know a spider-man I go wow that
one line really cleared that whole thing
why we're all theorizing why he has a
totally different suit in Europe you
asked me after the movie like what my
favorite suit was in the film and I
don't know about what aesthetically my
favorite suit was but I will say that
the the final suit ended up being my
favorite because he made that suit he's
been given so many suits and the thing
that was neat about that particular suit
as compared to all the other ones is
that throughout the battle you can see
it getting ripped up and it feels like
it's actual tangible material because
yeah as cool as the iron spider suit is
it actually detracts from the effect for
me because I'm like oh it's it's all
nanotech and it's a computer and it's
kind of fundamentally outside what I at
least associate with spider-man so
seeing him yeah like really take
ownership of this more classic suit
again just made me happy inside happy
happy made me Hogan one side happy
helped a lot he said when he builds a
suit and then you get to that crazy
third act finale which of course more
awesome visuals are just infused
throughout I gotta say I love what
they've done with the spider sensibility
calling it the Peter tingle that's my
favorite things funny with the Peter
tingle element I think it's great how
they've been building up the spider
sense power because from the franchise
of the not just the comics of the show
but then also the the Tobey Maguire one
the Andrew Garfield one it's just the
thing he has a spider sense it's one of
his things and here they're showing that
it's really a special unique ability
about being able to trust himself and
trust his instincts you know be able to
follow his intuition they're honing in
on it to me this is the coolest the
spider sense has ever been even though
it's not really present through a lot of
the movie but I contributes to its
becoming an actual moment when it does
appear yeah what he has to ultimately
defeat Mysterio in his sequence what
does he say come get away from her you
[ __ ] no like when when he Mysterio puts
him in when he's on the bridge with him
and he puts him in the illusion game
this is like to call it it made the
spider sense that much cooler because of
the fact of how they've been building up
this power how it comes from this idea
of having to trust himself kind of
harkens a little bit to spider-man 2 of
being able to and this is like a
spider-man to Sam Raimi spider-man to
being able to embrace his inner self in
order to be able to use his powers it's
kind of a thing that we got here of in
order to feat Mysterio and be able to
trust a spider sense to defeat this mind
game he has to be able to trust his own
mind and heart so I loved the way they
handled the spider the spider sense here
thoughts
no I Green also to I'd say they yeah
yeah you didn't say much there yeah it
also I'd also say too that they they
kind of heard some of the complaints you
know from the other movies that didn't
really focus on his spider sense I mean
even though we saw glimpses of it in
Civil War and homecoming and in infinity
war we did CEO because memory could
sense you know rip for the guardians
came and all that no I agree with you
they handled in a very mature and
interesting way and was done differently
than it's been done in the other films
and was just executed just in a way were
him like well I was really interesting
it gives it a quality that he's still
growing in to the full extent of his
power that just makes for a nice set of
details as this is part of you know a
franchise that will go for installments
you know yeah it does make first sort of
an evolutionary process with him not
just like okay he's got all the powers
and maybe he'll have a new suit next
time movie ends he's back to New York
and it's all dandy or is it then I'm not
gonna like they did show one of those TV
spots and there with him and everybody
just Sony can't help themselves
sometimes when they show those n TVs
major spider-man twenties I thought I
gotta ended funny and then I thought
that the first post-credit scene was the
actual ending of the movie and they were
like let's put a little break here
because if you don't watch that
post-credit scene it's a very different
ending yeah like you you can still have
the second post-credit scene and you get
the same exact movie that first
post-credit scene changes the whole
journey here that you've just been on
especially the final note before the
which I thought was very fascinating Jay
jonah jameson first appears on screen
commissioner gordon's in this rate it's
great some questions here is it just
like a fun cameo does that mean that
when jay jonah jameson is officially in
as a character not just like a little
fun thing
will he be merge in the movie man that's
the next phase do Marvel we're gonna
spin on all the non supers and now
you're saying that as a joke but I'd
actually be down but will it be JK
Simmons in the role I suppose it might
raise some questions well the rules what
are the rules here it is this is
establishing a multiverses that mean the
Tobey Maguire multiverse works but is
that why they didn't decide to put him
in any of the J jonah Jameson makeup
that they had him in for the Raimi
spider-man ones okay no this is so
different thing we just got the same
actor to do it he's really no other
actor who could do as well or is it like
this is an alternate-dimension and he
just looks a little different in this
one yeah it's like there's a lot of
possibilities that are a little vague it
can't be like the origin of it this
wouldn't make any sense
no yeah I hope I would be nice if
they're hinting it really actually the
multiverse and spider-verse and all that
bit I may be a spider-man is the one
character to the mall that would be a
freaking awesome to lend itself to oh my
god we got a Tobey Maguire Andrew
Garfield tom hollie that'd be crazy they
put together a special team but only you
three but anyway but to the big moments
of that or the fun nugget the scene
where Mysterio is pretty the ultimate
illusion where makes it look like
spider-man killed him also actually is
he he's dead dude before we go into this
sure is dead I figured that was a
posthumous thing yeah yeah so I was like
what's what's your endgame
yes he is part of a bigger organization
we're about to find out about but I was
like I guess you just really wanted to
take this kid down a peg on your way out
mister is actually dead but with that
moment though he tells everyone
it's like he's back in New York he's got
his crew everything's going good for
beer at this moment and then he tells
everyone that spider-man is Peter Parker
and then shows his picture oh god that
is a freakin and
right like people told me there's a
shocking post credit scene in Andhra and
I did not predict that I didn't come
anywhere near predicting that was a
complete blindside and they're smart
because it starts off so innocuous Lee
it starts out as one of those like well
this is gonna be a cute fun post-credits
scene or whatever you know just like add
a little button joke and then it is like
the most shocking elements the entire
movie sets up you're a part of three
four something guys thoughts ginger go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no I was just
gonna say like even if they would have
just ended the mid-credits scene there
as with Jay jonah Jameson one yeah yeah
GG Simmons back great then when you
actually get that reveal that you know
of Quentin Beck you know it's telling
the world they inspire my like oh my god
like what does this mean for the future
because spider-man is a kid obviously we
know in the comic book Civil War he
reveals his identity but that's on his
terms like this is kind of the
introverted reverse Iron Man where at
the end of Iron Man wine he tells the
world I am Iron Man and now Peter is
under duress and stress when the world
now finds out who he is because he's
very you know guided about his identity
so it's it's gonna be interesting seeing
like in the future I mean now we know JJ
Jameson will have no problem hiring him
if I can get any shot he wants of
spider-man but it is gonna be
interesting to see how they do this I
would want them to commit to this at
this angle and not reverse any of this
we've seen so many spider-man's store
it's it's in his DNA of the whole like
struggle with keeping his identity
secret and having a personal life and a
superhero long who loves to but then
this opens up a whole new door of a
completely different kind of spider-man
movie that we can get it has to really
challenge all those themes his
relationships everything so it got me
very excited for what they could do for
a sequel with his identity has always
been secret and almost everything we've
seen for his secret to be out there as
it you can never get a job at the Daily
Bugle of to see obviously everyone's
reaction I'm kind of curious is to
Flash's reaction because flash hates
Peter but do you love spider-man so it's
like what is he supposed to think in
that moment is gonna kiss him
he's gonna yeah he's gonna be full-on
gay on the next day now he's gonna
understand how why that slap hurts so
hard I feel like they'll be like plenty
of theories to go around till the next
spider-man movie what's gonna cool now
I'm like Wednesday next movie coming out
now at that point yeah
one is weird too because like the way
the post-credits scenes are organized it
goes from this like huge crescendo that
does make you wonder about like the
future of spider-man to this like still
interesting but lesser ending note where
you're like okay maybe we're maybe we're
getting a glimpse basically at like what
the sort of future look of the ends I
use gonna because you got Nick Fury on
this space station showing out and we
find out the Maria Hill and Nick Fury on
earth have been Scrolls the entire timer
art Alice and the other scroll the
entire time which felt like especially
on the heels of that just weird reveal
that made me go huh more than it
surprised or really drew me in so was it
just made me ask questions it was it
just that he wanted to take a vacation
but work still had to be done so he's
like you guys fill in for me it was just
dusted for five years he wanted I mean I
get again you can make the argument he's
already been gone for five years but I
mean we don't exactly know what he was
experiencing in the dut when he was a
you know decimated so everyone else
experiences that they were gone and then
they're back that's a pretty top level
you know organization I could see why he
needed a little break or why to get to
space so but is it actually setting up
something specific for us to like
experience or is this like a fun little
wink at the audience you know like I'm
not like you I'm a little bit more in
that arena of I'm kind of confused as to
what the point of this what what what is
this is this what is this setting up
clear there was a Nick Fury before the
decimation happened right the want the
funeral that's really Nick Fury so why
did he do this they have a bigger
mission he's working on and he was just
on break that we cut to you or is he on
that bigger mission and just you know
he's in transit or something or yeah I
that was the best explanation I could
come up with was as well he's just
working on the next most important phase
of whatever the Avengers have to do now
the only concrete thing I've heard is is
not
creet because it's a rumor that phase
four will be more heavily caused with an
earth-based and so that's kind of how i
read that post scene was okay the Nick
Fury is gonna be running things from
space and we're gonna do a lot of space
yeah
which hey I mean I'm down to Leesburg
you realize Tower one posters up but
they both they both will leave us very
strong surprising impression that's yeah
sure now we recovered the main big ones
Tom Hollands and daya I love their
chemistry yeah they're really good I
mean I really did find myself so
invested in their relationship that but
when we get to the end like they really
I mean Betty Brant said it perfectly for
us they're just so cute together yeah I
know I kind of went a little off topic
there but I just wanted to say that
before we ended like those two are
really good together we got a lot of
people who love the original ones and I
I do too not spider-man three as much
you know I felt they have a different
kind but a better chemistry than Kirsten
Dunst in time of iron and how many get
killed for saying that but I do like
their chemistry a lot they really do
click together even though they've got
different personalities there's just
like there's a end of their yang I mean
the Indian her yang they really just do
work together really well well speaking
of the relationship art one thing I want
to say that I love the way they handle
the Betty Brant and Ned because they get
on the flight and that whole situation
happens you're watching like little
montage moments of what like oh they're
clicking right I think the reason why it
worked so much for me was because of the
joke that landed so well when they got
off the plane when Peter it goes up to
him he's like what's that guy's name did
Davis character Brad Brad Brad yeah but
he's like mg was Scenic's to Brad the
whole time and they were laughing and
having such a great time he's like it's
not a big deal they were just on a plane
they're just sitting there who cares the
exact same experience that was very
clever writing like that literally the
writing of that made the whole rest of
that bit works so well for me because of
how they introduced that because I know
some people have felt that that one joke
Ned is not much of a character in here
and they sort of just resort to this
little bit they have with Betty I sort
of felt liked in order to
MJ more screentime and flush her out
better they had to sacrifice a little
bit of Ned time in order to do that we
thought it was so funny yeah I really
thought it was hilarious but even
backtracking a little bit more here I
like happy Hogan a lot in this film and
I like the relationship he's reformed
with Peter is not just like dude is just
criticizing the [ __ ] out of him it's
like from in homecoming yeah to see
where the relationship is now and a
little bit of a different change of
character because of the happy being
affected by the death of Tony as well I
thought it was great and he's dating his
aunt let's talk about that I I just have
majored ripes with the way Aunt May is
currently being handled like yeah I
didn't mind at all you know in civil war
uh hot and Marissa Tomei that's funny
that's cool he's younger sure why not
who cares and then at homecoming you get
little scenes here or there where you
see some of their relationship I still
don't really feel much for it I just
couldn't help but question the dynamics
between Peter and Aunt May in this movie
I totally get that you oh yeah we've
seen the origin tale a bunch of times
it was great power comes great
responsibility we've heard that quote a
bunch of times
the same time though at the same time
I'm not here to make an argument exactly
of how that is such an integral
ingredient to the Peter Parker
characters I do feel strongly about that
I want to talk strictly about the
relationship between Aunt May and Peter
Parker dude they're just buddies in this
film and it to me it undercuts so much
of it could be a lot of debt at the end
of the day the Ben Parker story does
exist they've hinted at it in homecoming
no civil war or to hinted at it and that
here there's the initials of BFP on the
luggage showing no that thing did happen
there's a reason why she's a single aunt
taking care of her nephew because she
had a husband who died so we have that
and then you also have the cliffhanger
of homecoming that was a great
cliffhanger when she sees Peter
spider-man and then it cuts to the
credits because oh man we haven't seen a
story yet where Aunt May knows Peter
Parker is spider-man her nephew and
there's just no weight to the
relationship in especially in this movie
it's all gone did she just pimp and him
out in the beginning high-fiving him
great job you're doing
I'm gonna kind of criticize you and how
stiff you were out there and she seems
to be more in tune for this joke for
happy Hogan and them dating which I'm
like we already kind of getting that
joke with Betty Brant and Ned so yeah it
really felt like a lesser version of
that joke and it was a bummer because it
completely waters down heavens presence
and contribution to the movie and it's
like you could have made her still a
very enjoyable hip character while also
making her feel like an actual person
with a relationship to Peter who might
care very much about his well-being you
know it also didn't family maybe I'm
wrong but it didn't feel like he had
been gone for fire cuz I'm assuming she
survived the snap he was actually gone
from the snapped oh okay it doesn't
matter yeah so it seemed like a concern
Dan like whenever he's in danger in
trouble like it yes decent get the
feeling the wards danger in this movie
yeah yeah like okay that's your nephew
there's no extra layer of that's still
my nephew I'm still his guardian he's
still a 16 year old boy you know there's
none of that present they sway so much
away from that because the the the MCU
seems so intent on not covering any of
Uncle Ben I get you don't want to fully
explore it but it is it is an integral
part to his character it's an integral
part to the whole dichotomy of the
relationship between and me and Peter
Parker if you don't want to use any of
like specifics of Uncle Ben at least add
layers of gravitas to the some of the
conflict that could form from the
relationship and said she just seems so
breezy about everything I do take big
issue with that it's use her for more
than just hot and who's cool no it was
cute and charming in Civil War for the
five minute she's in there but if you're
gonna make her a character in the
franchise of spider-man use her and and
I saw yeah I have big issues with the
way they handle and speaking of adults I
thought that they were able to get it I
mean Peters understand well but some of
the other kids they were just able to go
wherever they wanted whenever they
wanted even when they were supposed to
be like at the Opera House they just
blocked out yeah it just felt like the
chaperones we're doing a really bad job
of chaperoning I see some of mine it
picks with is that's more nitpicking I
know I don't think it's a full
lonna pick cuz some of my criticisms
that come with the first half of this
movie
whereas I felt in homecoming the comedy
really meshed super well I felt like in
the first half overall really funny film
but there was some moments that I could
just feel like okay they're doing a
comedy bit they're doing a comedy scene
we're taking time to do comedy right
here and it seemed like especially with
the teacher characters that they really
just like made them total jokes there
becomes a point at which there are two
kinds of characters in the movie they're
characters that feel like actual
characters that fit whatever the conceit
of the world is and then you got a bunch
of joke characters yeah who only exists
to be jokes and who don't have any other
dimension besides that oh so one of the
teachers you remind me of one of the
lines we got a name and the watch this
is the work of gypsies is like it's
witches
it's definitely witches oh yeah yeah
which is funny it's like that there are
all these things that are funny but
without any kind of contrasting temper
them they just it becomes like that guy
at the party who's like I would like to
just have a conversation with you though
like yeah you don't always have to be
you know always have to hit me with the
one way you're watching you made it this
far buddy I hope you know it's you I
like the opening blip though moment how
they I was like the Peter Parker put
this together but what they may share
that it's the I thought that was like a
really clever way to add levity of a way
to transition properly after endgame
something so much weight into this movie
I thought that was really clever
watching that sequence made me want to
watch the movie bodyguard yeah I guess
some questions that I do have are the
elementals that are they man Durand were
they never real because in the comics
they're real characters or real villains
this movie there are only illusions I
know they were talking about how hey
there are some things in mythology that
are real like Thor so will we see the
real elementals ever appear again chem
fighty has yet to live up to his word on
the idea of the mandarin coming back
saying that or they just characters they
don't care to explore so what we see a
real version of them even though I love
the Mysterio sequences there are some
things about it that nitpick questions
not really like criticism of the movie
but just more like wait a minute kind of
completes on how this works like when he
is toying with spider-man's mind
are they illusions that you know the
Mysterio and team worked together on of
like doing D like psychological
background research don't be here be
like we got to create specifically this
for this thing to really pull out him or
was he using barf technology and to go
into his mind so can he see into like so
some of those things were a little bit
questionable to me not in the immediate
moment just like leaving the screening
and I was like wait how did this work
exactly overall yeah great time and I
really liked how there were actually
plenty of like really cool spoilers to
talk about with this movie things I'm
like I got it the second half of this
movie no yeah once it's like no okay
it's official he's definitely a villain
it becomes like spoiler from that on out
yeah anyway guys what were your favorite
moments from spider-man far from home
what were the biggest the biggest like
shocking things to come out of this film
were you disappointed by did you love it
leave a comment down below Andrew thanks
for being here make sure to go check out
his youtube channel movie source channel
follow him on social media at a core 711
we're the real rejects subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell & Skillshare thank you guys so much
for sponsoring this video don't forget
to sign up for your free two-month trial
link in the description box and pin
comment